well I don't know that every manager in
the world who's a Buddhist is
necessarily a good manager on the other
hand there are certain elements of
Buddhism I think are very positive for
management especially now such as let go
of the past and if you look at coaches
there was a study done on coaches and
Buddha believed that anyone can change
you know what the study showed coaches
who believe people can change are much
more effective than those who do not
believe people can change you know well
amazingly some people don't believe
other people can change
another pretty useless is coaches so I
my Buddhist philosophy is a simple one
it basically involves let go of the past
accept what is
move forward make the best of what you
have be happy in content